so yeah hi I'm Luis I'm going to be
talking about scalability in Cuba
Nattie's today if you want to get a hold
of me and tell me how bad I did
yesterday and you can visit my twitter
handle there we're going to do some live
demos today hence the song that we had
on before because if you're gonna be
done you'd better be tough so let's get
started so here's an agenda of what
we're gonna go through in the next hour
I'm gonna just give a bit more of an
introduction to myself about myself I'm
gonna show you the application that
we're going to be doing a live demo of
then we all talk about scalability and
we have them focus on the live demo at
the end of it then I'll give some tips
I'm free new to kubernetes well I've
been doing it now for about two years
and I was just gonna share the things
which I wish I knew two years ago which
I had to find out myself so please take
photos if there's anything on the slides
that you want to take home with you then
please take a photo I'll make a slides
available at the end as well now I've
got some of my favorite speakers also
take the opportunity to share some
things I've started tech at the start
there talks so for me one of them is
mental health I've suffered from
depression in the past I still have
anxiety and I'm not an expert about it
but it's just to say that it happens to
me I'm sure it happens forever and again
I wish I knew in my 20s that I wasn't
even one with it the other one is
climate change I was talking about
Captain Planet briefly yesterday it's
interesting data centers produced a 2%
of the emissions of global emissions
different cloud providers use green
energy some of them don't it so there's
a bitly link very if you want to learn a
bit more about cuz it's quite
interesting I've been consulting for a
while and I provide workshops keeping
addy workshops and I do that with well I
used to do that with company called in
Cuban at ease as of today I'm now
working with company called jet stack
thank you too kind the other thing and I
also do is I run a meet-up from Wales
so Wales is in the United Kingdom
there's some stuff happening over there
at moment I'm actually running a meet-up
right now this moment so it's I mean TPS
one it's amazing
so why keep a Nettie's I worked in the
industry for about 10 years and I was
consulting and I got frustrated that I
was in dependency and I was a dependency
for about two o'clock in the morning
when everything failed and I I really
like my sleep so I was looking towards
solutions for this I ended up looking
towards containers and as I'll talk
about later on
initially windows containers weren't
really they were announced two years ago
but they weren't great so I ended up
moving across to using them within Linux
but now we're seeing a shift back to
Windows so we'll come to that later on
but let's start with the application and
we're going to be doing if you look at
container projects containers are great
because you don't have to be worried
about what runs inside them so when you
started trying to use a demo examples
and search you'll find that they've got
Ruby they've got rather they've got yeah
we got this and that and I don't know
all of them
I know I know dotnet so the application
that we got here today it's all written
in dotnet core I'm looking to update it
to be running in.net as well
we've cube naty's now supporting windows
and to show that as an example but all
of this is also available on my github
page so all the code that you see today
you can use and download it yourself and
then you can play back with look at all
my bugs and please help out with any
pull requests that you like and if you
go on there I am if you go on there then
you'll see the repos that have a code so
the application get ready for I hope
some of you saw Amy and lemons talk
about CSS this is my ability of CSS so
I've got a button and it's a ticketing
website so when he go into this website
I only got I only want you to do one
action which is to click get ticket when
you click on to get a ticket when you're
taken to a processing screen now this
processing screens gonna show Tim know
what you've done is is that you sent a
ticket to a message queue now have a
message queue is being watched by a
number of workers the workers for some
reason take five seconds I might have a
sleep in for five seconds in there that
might be what it is but after five
seconds it's going to take you to a
video of people applauding because
whenever I give a talk I really get
applause so I thought I'm gonna force it
force it today
so without further ado let's have a
quick sneak peek at it there we go so
here's our website let's hope this works
so I click on get tickets signalize
there that doesn't look like it's
working just yet
demo gods I'm just when I work Sokka
should just be patient always be patient
there we go Alex a little bit better so
you can see that it's processing a new
challenger has approached okay that we
didn't want to boo really and I don't
want you to see any suggested videos and
please don't look too much into what
I've previously been yeah is there our
Griffins they don't know me that well
let's have a quick look so let's see
what's happening there so I'm gonna do
cube cuddle edit deployments so I hope
you can all see this okay
within kubernetes we use deployments to
say what we want to run this is y amal
and what we'll find is is that oh he's
our image that we're running so I got
ticketing worker but I've got the boot
AG not for yayyy tag which that's how I
do my versioning so I'm just gonna
update that too yay I'm gonna save it
and quit it so let's clear that and
we'll just see get parts and we're gonna
watch just to see that we got some parts
crayons so we can see that once okay
once been creating ones running so if I
now do that command again but without
watch okay one still terminating but
once running so if we go back to the
website
hopefully we'll get a bit of a better
response so our applications working in
the UK we go to the pub about now but
I'm gonna talk about scalability and
robustness things happen things get
released and we all want to get a nice
new shiny thing which usually means that
we get spikes in our internet traffic
now from the UK we're about six hours
ahead of you here so it usually happens
in the afternoon for us whereas I think
it happens in the morning for you but
how do you manage with these spikes so
how do you deal with so much of this
traffic well the solution is usually to
have a back end and a front end so we'll
have a back end REST API and then we
could have a website we could also have
apps because we like apps and all of
these could connect onto the background
recipe API so let's plan for launch so
if there's a user and they go to the
website and it has one back-end so we
wanted to scale them out so we have four
backends because I think the u.s. US
Marines say one is none two is one so we
want to scale that that out and for us
be able to share the traffic across fact
we all put something in place which we
call a load balancer but as well mede
also for our website we have to create
multiple instance of it and put an ever
load balancer on top of that let's try
to do some performance tests so our web
application has a limit of a thousand
requests our back-end has a limit of 250
requests so that means that we've got a
ratio of one to four so let's get ready
so we've got to this point in the day
now I'm going to send some traffic to
our website
so the loads coming in but because we've
got a one-to-one relationship there
between our website and our back-end
then one of the backends can't handle
all of that traffic so all the sudden
we've gone from having for free and then
the other one can't handle the traffic
the next and it's all time to go offline
by this point you've got someone with a
job title Stan we've see something
Oh Stan to contact the event saying the
website's gone down so you after you've
made your coffee you go back to you to
ask and then you scale it up so now
we've got 8 backends and all of a sudden
we can handle over traffic again but
it's one fundamental issue with that
it's too little and it's too late we've
lost a lot of time and potentially lots
of sales so let's do a little bit of
chaos engineering with this and we'll
just add more users and so actually one
of the websites have gone oh no all the
websites have come down now and but some
of the traffic's still coming through
and the backends just it's no it's game
over
we're not managing this well enough
we're reacting to it but it's dependent
on ourselves it is a nice story that I'm
sharing but we all know about this lots
of covant as I have a who will tell you
that they can managers themselves
Amazon's own website crash on their
biggest day being you've a date when I
was going to happen but it still went
down and it was quite a lot of people
knew about it
so they didn't have enough service to
handle for traffic search for a day
Amazon had to manually add service to
address the issue and they fail to add
them fast enough so what could you
improve how about automatic scaling so
instead of it being dependent on you
being at your desk and then finding out
these stats how about if something else
can monitor stats for you also can we
decouple the scaling so we saw that our
web front-end application it was a one
to four ratio with a back-end so could
we scale the backend separate to the
front end so there's our ratio if we add
another website on then we could just
add another four api's but then we
improve performance that we have
available in our back-end and then we
now can use a ratio of one to two and we
can continue to manage that also Preedy
couple failures so if we have a document
going in five website so it gets four
website and it gets processed that's
great
good times now if we go to process a
document and but none of the backends
are available it goes through a website
and then it would just die death or we
could just keep them up there but what
if instead we used a message broker so
we have our user they go to the website
and they start creating some documents
and we fill the map onto the message
broker and then we can pass it through
the backend so we can now scale
independently we can add more back-end
resources and they can listen to the
same message queue and essentially we
can start now handling the failures so
even if a back-end isn't available we
can still load up the message queue what
about automatic scaling there are a
number of options available to us we've
got meat sauce ECS we got keeping at
ease as you probably were made aware by
the title of my talk we're going to be
too
got some keeping at Easterday reasons
for this well it's open source is lots
of contributions happening to it now and
it's gaining lots of momentum small t
cloud so it's an abstraction on top of
cloud providers so we don't need to know
about the special source about each of
the cloud providers due to manager
instances we can just learn Cuba
nettings and it's designed to scale so
we can scale independently we can handle
failures and we've got automatic scaling
so that sounds like a plan to me I think
that's what we're gonna go towards now
keep an eye T's as an Orchestrator it
orchestrates containers Cupid is not
Cupid I t's won't solve all your
problems
I would suggest focusing on your
containers first that's where you can
get through biggest wins so for an
example of our container we have a
dotnet application we have some assets
in there let me compare away if we want
in container really we could even have a
cat for all I care because all I'm
interested in is being able to run this
container I don't need to know what's
happening inside it I just need to know
how to run it so let's look at deploying
apps in to keep it at ease this is an
example of what I've got running for the
live demo so I've got a front-end
application and I've got back-end now
those look a bit like the load balances
that I talked about earlier on within
keeping out he's free to call them
services about layer when it's going
onto the pods I've also got a message
queue and I have a service for that and
then I have a worker and the worker is
now part of an auto scaling group so
today we're going to use horizontal pod
auto scaling as an example of how it's
going to work
lessons learned in scaling with
kubernetes this is what it looks like
our compute so this could be bare metal
service or this could be a virtual
machines each of your worker nodes would
require to have a binary and so-called
Keyblade
so cubelet is what's listening to a
while cross communicating with you or
keeping out he's master and to find out
if it's got any work to do cubelet would
then find if it does have work to do it
communicate to the doc a daemon running
on that node so as affine cipher has
containers to run air to fill out those
nodes once we got to the state of having
free full nodes the solution to this
would just be to add more notes trip we
can start filling the map to but not all
containers have a same shape or size so
this time I'm showing you the master
node so master node by standard is just
focusing purely on the control plane of
cuban Hattie's and so it's delegating
ever work so be able to notice there our
our work notes so when we have container
come through it would dedicate the best
know to put it into when I never
container comes available then he'll
delegate again so then all of a sudden
we start to find out that it's actually
one of the best Tetris players we've had
have had I need to allocate as much of
resource as possible so we get the most
of our machines out of the compute that
we're paying for if you have a benefit
would keep a Nettie's is just a rest api
so it has its own swagger documentation
so you could interact with this on an
API level yourself you could build your
own clients do things if you wanted to
you can extend it you can build your own
controllers so you can build whatever
you want with it right
so it's demo time so having the
opportunity of having you all in this
room I thought it'd be best instead of
me just doing that live demo myself I'd
ask all of you to join in so if you
could go to
development squad calm on your phone or
on your laptops and we're going to again
I like breaking things
so please could you put your phones on
as loud as possible and your laptops on
as loud as possible first have you got
one there so we should start hearing
some cheers hopefully development squad
comm congratulations we've got a bit of
an issue here though because I've got
that sleep waiting for five seconds when
something we're just queueing up our
message queue and we're only getting one
so cheers and this isn't really very
euphoric ending that I wanted to my talk
I'd have much rather too if everyone was
screaming and cheering and actually
doesn't seem too good right now because
only two have happened there so let's
look how we can change this so again if
I go to if I do keep color get parts I
can see all my parts running and I can
see I've got it to consume worker thank
you again this is when we start here
over cheers whilst I carry on you get
used to this after a couple of minutes I
promise you we can see we've got one
ticketing worker and also you can see
that it's got two of two ready
now within kubernetes we don't call it
containers we call them pods yeah we'll
see I think I was five seconds we call
them pods
now pods don't have to have a single
container running in within them you
could have multiple containers running
in there it's
just think of it as having a virtual
machine the only thing that you need to
be aware of is that you can't expose on
the same port so if you had two
containers running in they're both
trying to shave something on port 3000
it's not gonna work so the two that I've
got running in within ticket worker and
I've got one which is for worker process
which is just a console application the
every one is an API now that API is
connected to our message queue and then
it will give us an output just to show
how many tickets we got remaining
remaining in the queue so at this point
let me clear my screen we're going to do
a load test because it's lots of us here
but we're going to try and prep this
probably I'm warming up so I'm gonna do
an a/b test but instead I'm gonna do it
for 200 I think I've typed that all
right
so this is Griffin Ravana is connected
to our prometheus
so Prometheus is scraping the data and
we can start to see that the low test is
going through and is picking up with
Prometheus when it comes out of a box
he'll just get regular stats who will
get stats off your nodes that you would
expect and a few containers such as you
CPU system one now the other thing that
we can do with Prometheus is is like we
can create our own custom endpoints as
well so that we can share our own data
so I could connect this to the API that
I'm running within the worker so we can
actually see from from cuba Nettie's can
see how many tickets we got in a message
queue so we can see that graph up there
and again my time management isn't great
I don't know if I'm gonna last for a
whole hour here so we could just watch
this go down every five seconds but I
don't think anyone would want that so
let's have a look at something else
let's have a look at our ticketing queue
now we've got a file here let's see if
it'll fit in the screen cool so this is
my llamo for my horizontal part
autoscaler now when I pass this into
Cuba Nettie's what its gonna do is it's
gonna realize that the minimum amount of
replicates what I want and running any
one moment in time will be 10 and the
most of all I want running 20 and I want
to see that I have a target average of
free so let's pass her in to keep my
keys now
just clear that screen cube color apply
- file HV so it's worked it's great so
if I have a look at my pods I can still
see that there's only one ticketing
worker on there at the moment now the
reason for this is it takes 30 seconds
for it to find find the update when it
does recognize that I've now got HP in
place it's gonna update my deployments
to having instead of a single ticketing
worker it's going to set it to ten to be
the minimum which I'm hoping will happen
anytime when I turn my back there we go
it's only set to our minimum at the
moment because we have way that the auto
scaling will happen is it'll just start
monitoring the queue and then it's after
I believe it's gonna be a free minute
period ill update 2:20 now instead of
leaving a spring here we'll do is so you
can see that with a single worker we're
steadily going through and we're
starting to take down the tickets now
that we've got ten available we should
see some more data points coming online
and we should see that declining at a
faster rate hopefully live demos know
I've got about three minutes of filler
here so let's try and do that so why
have I got three minutes of filler
well because I'm using a aks to do this
I'll ever draw a bellows speaking to the
AES team out here and have a moment I've
got no loyalties I just want to go to
whatever the cheapest services or
whoever can give me for most credits for
free but when it's hosted the beauty
with aks with assur is that they pay for
your masternode so when I showed you
vanilla Tilly run and one with
kubernetes logo on the masternode
Microsoft cover that bell for you you
don't have to pay for that virtual
machine now if you ever work modes
you've got to pay for so votes knows our
virtual machines you're paying for the
virtual machines that time what you
can't do is is that when you're not
developing with it you can turn them off
and when you turn them off you're not
paying for them and so all of a sudden
you can have a keep notice cluster but
you can develop on and you can turn it
off when you're not using it so that's
why I use a chaos at the moment and yeah
and so we can start seeing that the pods
are doing that they start to work
through that workload work through that
workload there but let's have a look so
let's see how we're doing with a number
of parts up you have so if I do keep
Carl get deployments I can see that
ticketing worker has been set to a
desired state of ten and currently ten
are there
and Tanner available and up-to-date so
I'll put a watch on that because
hopefully I'll go up to 20 in a moment
now we could declare in the state to
keep in at ease that's the only thing
that happens when he asked people to
turn on their phone some coyotes are you
getting phone calls but that's fine
we're all cool yes
we're declaring the state with keeping
at ease so what might happen over time
is is that we might have an odor drop
out for containers will come and go and
and that's great and that's what we
expect to happen and this is all just
about chaos engineering I don't
I want cuban at ease just to know what
my desired status this is what I want my
application to be like and that's why
that's why I get to stay in bed at 2:00
o'clock in the morning now it's a focus
on your monitoring and logging and
because then either your possible
restart your container what your
workload should go carry on you're still
gonna have to wake up occasionally at 2
o'clock in the morning I guess but the
main thing is is that we've got a
fighting I feel that we have a fighting
chance for keeping I used to be able to
manage our stress structure so I'm again
live demo times and for fears let's just
have a quick look we've got a message
queue down to there let me just put a
few more messages in from what it gets
okay so while Seth's going on then I'm
gonna just go back to my slides for a
second I've pinned my clicker somewhere
and I don't know where so tips I'd like
to give tips it was only two years ago
but I went to my first conference I
never before I get into public speaking
I had no desire to and I just wanted to
try and find a community that I could
work with and my career path has been
very weird and that's for another story
over an ever beer but these are
off-the-record tips and these are things
that no one that I've worked with would
share and this just me being completely
honest and this is why I'd like to share
with you if you'd be interested in
working with keeping at ease so yeah I
mentioned earlier on about when I got
started with keeping IDs I sorry start
with containers
it was always Linux and I didn't know
Linux I only knew Windows I started off
as a developer I ended up as a Windows
dev and I ended up you doing c-sharp now
I didn't start becoming a developer
because I wants to learn c-sharp I
became a developer because I wanted to
learn how to solve problems now I'll go
to a well-known search engine and I try
and find material to be able to
understand how to use containers now
I've got a wealth of knowledge within
Windows but I don't have any knowledge
within Linux but there's a great book
that I found and it's by a chap called
Elton Stillman called docker on Windows
now he's just released for second
edition so this was a first edition he
was released in 2016 the second edition
now he's got examples with Windows
Server 2019 I'd recommend if you're
looking at running containers to read
this book it's got some great examples
and you'll be able to get up and running
with your containers nowadays Microsoft
loves Linux so I mentioned as you're a
couple of times they have Brandon burns
as currently working on the azure team
Brandon burdens is one of the founders
of kubernetes we've seen with msbuild
there's so much progress now within
Microsoft and it's phenomenal and the
rate of change that's happening various
great and it's just well I feel that as
a community it's
just pushing in the right direction and
they also have helm which is now
acquired by Microsoft but there's some
epoxy hey there's a good friend as Sam
Newman he will forever tell me that you
don't have to use Cooper Nettie's and I
completely agree with that
Cooper Nettie shouldn't be a selling
point about what's great about your
product Cooper netting should be the
hidden thing doing all the work for you
and when I run workshops and speaking to
the teams you're looking at occasionally
like estimating about 25 percent of your
team might have to manage Cuban Hattie's
if you do it on bare metal so it might
not solve a problem if you're just
hosting your own blog site
I don't host my blog site on Cuba
Nettie's I'd be yeah I would just be
waiting match so you don't always have
to use it and this is from my pep comm
talk last night so conference bingo here
always seeing containers showing like
this which is cool I understand the
concept but we don't care what's inside
the container that's why Amazon ship
their parcels all in the same box
because it was fits into fake nodes
being their delivery trucks but mr.
meeseeks is a perfect example of what
Catina should be and the containers
should have one job to do and it should
be able to do it well and it should be
able to die gracefully so on that point
when I start developing my applications
now the first thing I focus on is is how
will it start so you can have management
with 16 requests so when a container is
stopped you can manage it within your
code base to be able to catch capture
that and stop a process grace for you
rather than just kill it
there's the CN CF as well so the CN CF
of a cloud native computing foundation
now they've got a great website which is
called landscape CN CF de IO
but you can just use it l dot CN CF - I
am and what that shows you is it shows
you all the products currently available
within the CN CF whenever you hear the
latest new thing within
cuban at ease so for example if you
heard about SEO you can go in on their
phone you can find us - you can find out
also other products are available that
isn't sto but in the same same way to be
able to decide what you should be using
now the other really useful tool that
you can get from its website is if you
just send an e for heading of a website
you can click on the trail map now this
trail map was created to show you how to
become creative so you start on point
one being containerization so again
that's the most important part is if you
get you man if you get containers
managed correctly then everything should
work through quite well then you've got
CI CD and then you've got Orchestrator a
point free so to get the most basic set
up to become native it would be to get
the orchestrator level anything after
that is a bonus there's a great term as
well that I've recently learned which is
called buy learn back so when I got to
started with some of these I'd have to
install lots of different things and and
there's so many steps where I could fail
out when trying to get up and running
with a new Riven
like we have a new language or trying
out a new product but there's a website
called cutter coder has anyone used car
decoder before in here oh so we got a
couple great it's run by a chap called
Ben hole and he's been really supportive
with in my career and live in the
community that we've set up you can go
on there onto the website there's lots
of different scenarios again it's you as
an example or my proxy scenarios where
she can start straightaway and it
connects onto a virtual machine
elsewhere by the web browser so you
don't have to install anything you just
connect via the web browser and then you
get to learn back finally learn simple
things are hard way there's a couple of
great books and I knew part I knew some
of Bosch but there's a book called learn
Bosch for hard way by and me he'll and
show you two other quick tips just be
able to use Bosch now I I must admit
I've used frameworks occasionally to be
able to do really simple tasks but then
I'm using a framework and then that
takes lots of space stuff like bash it
just helps be able to manage these
processes and if you went if you're
interesting again the book if you get it
from here because that's the best price
for it but it's a digital book as well
see I think this is a final tip I would
give on this is create your own private
cloud I've created my own private cloud
on raspberry PI's so I've got six
raspberry PI's I've got one is a master
and I got five work notes on that I'm
running websites I've got civilus
functions running on there and a number
of different containers and whatnot but
it was a great way to be able to start
getting experience as to what Cuba
Nettie's was at home and being able to
do my own chaos engineering so ripping a
pair out in search now what's next
within kubernetes keep an eye you snows
eyes of Cuban at least 1.14 it's now
supporting windows nodes and I think
there's going to be a big shift now and
to people picking up but keeping IDs
from our windows background to that and
does anyone know what the strangler
pattern is okay we got a couple cool so
strangled pattern is based on the
strangler fig which is it's a plant that
lands on a tree as soon as that plant
lands on the tree it'll start to grow
roots down when the roots grow down to
the bottom of the base of a tree then it
starts to take off for nutrients away
from the tree eventually you'll end up
with a host tree dying and they need to
have a tree with a hollow center so why
am I talking about trees we could do
this with our applications so if you're
running a monolith at this moment in
time there's no reason why you can't
stick that in a container once you've
done that you could use a load balancer
above that and to be able to direct
traffic to a new container so you could
be creating a new website in another
container for your application form for
example and then that load balancer
could say that anything that goes to
apply it goes to a new container and
with this new code base this means that
you don't have to change anything within
their legacy application so if you've
ever personally from when I've had it
trying to change the monolithic code as
part of it fails but I don't know where
it's failed doing something like this
means that I don't have to change
anything within that monolith and I can
start looking at building up the
microservices until the point where I
can just move everything across into a
modular approach
so again just say bike line eight wheels
and the reason I'm saying this is is
that this is the thing that has caused
me to accelerate so much more of my
career and it's by giving back
unity where I'm from I was telling
conferences in London and round Europe
it's my first time coming to America but
it's helping other people out and I
didn't know most about Cuban at he's 2
years ago but what I could do is is that
I knew how to manage a house party so I
just created a house party and we've got
lots of people coming so right now
there's a house party happening with 120
people in Cardiff which is our biggest
one yet doing that though having other
people see you help others in it's a
good way for people to help you - as its
had the biggest impact on my career so
finally with this then I think I've
probably talked way too long and we
would have lost
deployment yeah we've gone down to the
state of Tennessee for sis through I was
hoping that I'd keep it at 20 and then
I'd ask all of you - oh I'm gonna have
this lead actually sir everything goes
so well until the end live - Emerson
never doing this again ticketing Q given
LEDs
so if you could go on to an development
squad dot-com
and then if you could request a ticket
no live demos see it's probably your
absolutely failing on him anyway well
I'll leave it there we'll see if we get
any noises never gonna do it like them
like this again it's being novel home
thank you for your time if you do have
any questions I'll be here to take on I
[Applause]
am yes so um so I'm only used in signal
are more as a chat process so when the
work has spin up they connect on signal
are as well so you pretty much just
watching a chat screen on that terminal
window there it was only just to show
I'm using for civilization other that
it's just being released yeah but it was
soon just to show some common patterns
that we could use in there but again the
main thing for this demo was to show
vadym all of its within dotnet core so
if you want to go and have a look and
see how it runs for him is available to
you okay I got a boo so yeah yes sure
yes so within so the question was how
does the HPA work with the prometheus
matrix so the Promethea with prometheus
you can specify where the metric is so I
can say that there's an endpoint
available here on this pod and if you
listen to this bit I think it's a slash
ticket but I have on the API it gives
back the total number of tickets
available and then that's been scraped
as we could see on the graph on the
dashboard here that's a metric that's
being scraped there when the HPA is
running then it's when comparing that to
the required state that we'd want and
then what because it's not much from
there cried state then abuse pinging up
additional pods the most important thing
with the HPA and prosper be with
containers anyways is to know is to
focus on the CPM memory usage with any
containers because Kuban I just keep
adding them in and then essentially
could wipe out your own node which is
then bad times my hope answers
serve HPA's van connected to prometheus
endpoint metrics so we give a metric a
title so again I gave it a title of
ticketing and then Cuban identify
manages that within HPA to be able to
pull through that data and then that's
using a desired state to compare with
that metric value yeah
great comeback to crude
so yes so we specify that it's coming
from a part and the metric type is sell
tickets and we want to target average of
three and so that's what community's
disease and then to manage the number of
parts that we're spending up in response
to that no yeah
any of the questions I finished a little
bit early I do apologize it's live demos
I'm never knowing if you're gonna work
out and yeah yes
and so the tips I gave with HP aces is
fat because well with an aks because
there's a three-minute delay and we
won't have a minimum to a basis of
something that you'd allow so again it's
not at this moment in time is an
instantaneous and I assume if you manage
your own class or even build your own
ogre and Austria an extension for it
then you can look at rapidly updating
but within this and within a guess I
overestimate with having 10 workers
running them once and then also the way
that it scales up so it doubles it
initially so if I started with one then
it go to to van I go to four gonna go to
eight so that's something else that's
probably good to be aware so free minute
delay is just in when it scales up so if
I have a HP in place when you have a 30
second delay before the initial certain
aptiom min and then you're looking at
around if I have three minutes late I
have as one within a guess then to be
able to scale up but it's one of the
hand offs of using it as a managed
service compared to running humanize
yourself
well thanks a time and enjoy a recipe
conference